[Music]
of course today the only thing anyone's
talking about on television is the big
election and luckily for Americans our
local news stations across the country
are providing their own fresh take as
the campaign winds down take a look and
at 12:09 welcome back in the final days
of the campaign sometimes can get a
little salty
well final days of the campaign can get
a little salty the final days of the
campaign can get a little salty the
final days of the campaign can get a
little salty the final days of the
campaign if you get a little salty the
final days of the campaign can get a
little salty the final days of the
campaign can get a little salty the
final days of the campaign can get a
little salty the final days of the
campaign can get a little salty the
final days of the campaign can get a
little salty the final days of the
campaign can get a little salty and you
probably notice the final days of the
campaign have been well you might call
it just a little salty
you know who I want to meet I want to
meet cami Miami mountain boy they had
her parents had to know we're making a
newswoman it's name her cami mouth we'll
call her and her name shall be cami
mountain